rejoindre le pays Steven Spielberg
m'a approché sur un tel pont d'espions et
m'a demandé si je croyais que la marque PFT avait
une portée aussi profonde en tant qu'acteur et je voulais
que BFG ait l'air super photoréaliste Je
connais bien les chuchotements secrets du
monde et le seul moyen  Je pourrais capturer
que c'était pour l'animer en fonction de la performance de Mark,
vous emmenez Sophie dans un monde
de fantaisie et d'aventure qui fait partie
du grand amour et de l'amitié qu'ils ont l'un
pour l'
autre, car le BFG a vraiment touché mon cœur,
tout se résume à l'imagination dans le
Arrêtez vos souffles croisez les doigts on y
va